hey guys my name is Jess and you're just
stuck with me today I know we keep
changing hosts just want to keep you on
your toes
you're watching GameSpot youth and
here's what's been happening
first up original Xbox games are coming
to the backwards compatibility program
tomorrow and a Nintendo Direct is
scheduled for Wednesday the first
thirteen Xbox games will be playable on
Xbox one tomorrow
some choice additions on top of the
already revealed Crimson Skies high road
to revenge are black that sweet
first-person shooter from burnout studio
criterion Double Fine's dream invading
platformer cycle and the best RPG of all
time Star Wars the Knights The Old
Republic
just like with 360 games you can pop in
the physical disks of any of these games
and get to playing alternatively you can
grab a digital copy from the Xbox
Marketplace Xbox games don't support
achievements or online multiplayer but
they do support system link between
different generations of Xbox hardware
so that's pretty cool you can check out
the full list of games in our story on
GameSpot on the Nintendo front there
will be a Nintendo Direct tomorrow at 8
p.m. Pt focusing on the new mobile
version of Animal Crossing Animal
Crossing mobile was originally scheduled
to launch earlier this year but Nintendo
delayed it until the next financial year
so that could be any time from now until
March 31st of 2018 you can stream in
tomorrow night over on Nintendo's
YouTube page but don't fret if you can't
make it we'll be bringing you all the
news from the direct so keep tuning in
former Bioware dev manveer spoke on the
waypoint podcast about EAS motives
behind pushing microtransactions and
they are none too flattering AI recently
explained it would be closing Visceral
Games and altering the nature of its in
progress Star Wars game which will now
be created under a different studio this
is a trend industry veteran heir said he
witnessed firsthand as he explained EA
are generally pushing for more in from
the reason is you can monetize them
better it's the same reason we added Cod
packs to Mass Effect 3 how do you get
people to keep coming back to a thing
instead of just playing for 60 to 100
hours added the well he can't disclose
how much money heir has made off
microtransactions he has witnessed
people spending $15,000 on Mass Effect
multiplayer cards he went so far as to
say that visceral closing and this Star
Wars game being revamped is indicative
of the fact that court the linear
single-player triple-a game
attea
is dead for the time being I had a bunch
of other comments regarding the problems
of Mass Effect Andromeda and his
criticisms of the studio so go check out
the full interview if you're interested
finally the next main entry in the Shin
Megami Tensei series is coming
exclusively to Nintendo Swift
Atlas shed the info in a live stream
along with a teaser trailer showcasing a
subway station a lady and some flying
demons unfortunately there's not much
else to this one other than it will be
called shin megami tensei v and we'll
come exclusively to the switch atlas
hasn't confirmed if there will be an
international release but recent Shin
Megami Tensei games have been localized
to the west so there's hope there's also
a 3ds Shin Megami Tensei deep strange
journey that will release sometime this
year in Japan and early next year in the
u.s. that is everything I've got for you
today do let me know what you thought
about today's stories in that comment
box and if you're looking for something
else to do go check out our evolution of
GT a feature on GameSpot I'll see you
again tomorrow